[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça chante et ça danse c'est comm un
dimanche on va
rigoler et sonne les cloches sonne pour
la nose il sont
mariés maman se donne papa la console à
chacun son
t et vivent les filles qui perd sa
famille mais gagne
l'amour au dessert on chante chacun sa
romance même grand
papa qui a fait la guerre làbas en
Bavière et qui noublie
pas Paris madis
par bergè Volen froline promenade
caramel Volen
frine mais les petits
amoureux comme ils sont loin de tout ça
il se
caresse des yeux du bout des
doigts quand nous aurons beaucoup
d'argent nous meublerons là mais mais
comme cell du
patron petit
batapon les B le servant qui rou les
hanch passent les
plateaux le mer et Carl des
fr il a le cœur
chaud monsieur le Vic cherche une prière
pour ces
momentsl tandis que grandère compte dans
la bière l'exploit d'autre
[Musique]
fois promen
Caram mais les petits
amourux comme ils sont loin de tout ça
ils se dévorent
des yeux du bout des
doigs nous ferons beaucoup d'enfant et
le
premier justement avant qu'il ne soit
long petit
carnement voilà qui s'éloigne avec sa
compagne ils n'ont pas
SEM les célibataires et leur
fit bien
pareil làhaut la fenêtre sécla à la fête
bonne nuit les
petit tandis que grandpère noyé dans la
bière
[Musique]
continue
par
[Musique]
am les
amoure nuit de
no nuit
de Paris
Fran ça comme ça comme le chef
d'orchestre il aime bien comme ça super
magnifique vous savez he double modèle
comme ça
dans un petit pâ un petit pâ français un
petit pâ du 14 juillet ouais à
Strasbourg non comment à Colmar
était superbe magnifique on est Fran
mademoiselle comme ça solide fr on a
dansé comme ça tous les deux comme
ça
dans un petit
[Musique]
B Paris
za toujours
[Musique]
Paris
[Applaudissements]